can you animate Hagrid for me just do
some smart Hagrid smirked and looked up
from the buffet a firm tight flesh that
lays spread edge before him to tilt his
head questioningly what the [__] is
ready Glee what do you think Dumbledore
he murmured skimming a gentle hand down
there bound playmates spine then
slapping in hard lay on his buttock this
tick of weird plot Dumbledore grinned he
has been very good he said thoughtfully
tracing the crease of harry's hurt arse
with a fingertip I think he deserves
both dark Harry babbled something
incoherent with the frantic movement
Hagrid smiled wickedly then reached out
to wrap a hand and around
Dumbledore's neck pulling him close for
a hot and hard kiss for a long moment
the older men lost himself in familiar
tastes are good then the sound of an
indignant and
elected Harry broke into there less
driven snogging frenzy well someone just
feel ready Haggard and Dumbledore
chuckled as Dumbledore picked up as one
releasing Harry's bonds before he cast
lubrication spells Harry gasped then he
yelped when he felt rough hands all him
to his knees and the blood tip of
causing the entrance to his body yes
pushing back as Dumbledore thrust
forward [__] Harry
Dumbledore breathing surprise as a young
man's body gripped his car deliciously
next time Remus muttered crawling up the
bed to kneel before Harry he wound a
hand into the other man's messy locks
and yanked up his head rubbing his
weeping prick against his chin and lips
I want that [__] gorgeous mouth damn
it Harry what the [__] I'm going to [__]
your mouth Harry yes Harry met a noise
that Hagrid took to be an agreement and
he thrust experimentally and Hagrid
started to piston his hips with
abandoned giving himself over to the
feeling of that wet warm mouth around
his heart
needy comic guy Dumbledore plunged
feverishly into Harry's office he was
coming hard over Dumbledore's hand Agra
shudder to his own release after Harry
sucked him down to the base and
swallowed heard around his Hagrid fell
back onto the pillow spit Harry
collapsed onto his chest
and he felt Dumbledore fall to the
mattress then calling to him and after
we old dogs have a few minutes to
recover I do believe it Hagrid's turned
to bottom everybody he whimpered as
Harry's hand slid between his legs here
one key vestige be and yay I'm not gonna
light and that was weird oh god I wanna
burn she moaned as Anna felt her
sister's cup begin to swell up inside
moments before it blew yet another
fertile load of spa and their blood I
hear it